how does the title to this movie not
make you go I want to see this movie
like right now Cowboys and Aliens and
absurdly awesome title now I've been
looking forward to cowboys and Aliens
ever since the first trailer premiered
in the movie I don't know what movie it
was all I know is we were watching the
trailer the title Cowboys and Aliens
came up and everyone started cheering
cuz you're watching the trailer they're
all right Daniel Craig Harrison Ford
awesome Olivia Wilde
so I'm talking about and then cowboys
and Aliens is like I'm watching that so
if you really want to know the premise
of cowboys and Aliens just watch the
teaser trailer the first trailer that
came out it sums up the first 30 minutes
of this movie in like two minutes of
trailer Daniel Craig wakes up in the
desert he has no memory of who he is or
how he got there but he does have this
weird plus 45 willpower tech alien
bracelet on his wrist everyone could use
one of those and then he gets into town
he finds out he's a wanted man and then
aliens come and just start snatching
people up it's rafter that him Harrison
Ford and a band of people are like we're
gonna go get our people back and then
the Cowboys hunt the aliens aliens are
in it but it's really about the cowboys
and cowgirls kind of like imagine Rango
if Rango is called lizards and moles the
moles may be the ones causing the
problems but it's really not about the
moles it's about the main characters
staying with Cowboys and Aliens and I
actually really liked that I did go into
this movie with that Expendables mindset
where I was like alright I'm gonna go in
here I'm gonna turn my brain off and I'm
gonna watch Cowboys and Aliens just
fight for two hours but it's not really
like that it doesn't have a lot of that
mindless action and the character so
heard a little deeper than I expected
them to be
everyone knows Daniel Craig's cool
everyone knows Harrison Ford school but
their characters just had more layers
than I expected them to have in a movie
called cowboys and Aliens like imagine
going into Ninja Assassin I'm walking
out going
yeah the characters you know layers that
was cool I mean I expected Harrison Ford
to be like you know the old douchebag
that just causes problems like the
villain who's kind of talks like Batman
you came to me now I'm gonna take him it
kind of is but there's more to him than
that I like that I actually like the
side characters too like Olivia Wilde
other than the fact that you know she's
ridiculously high I don't think she
should be in movies because she
distracts me from movies I'm watching
this movie I'm just like Olivia Wilde I
forgot what they're doing right now
because I'm a big dumb guy it is what it
is what the movie is it's a Western if
you like westerns and you're gonna like
cowboys and Aliens it's a Western with a
little bit of a twist in it which I like
because you know the powers that be in
Hollywood are learning that if you want
a Western you need to do something new
because everything's been done in
westerns before you want something new
add aliens you not try Joe
hex that doesn't work no I actually did
like the aliens though I didn't know
what to expect but you know how aliens
are these days they apparently have the
intelligence to make tech and then they
just never use it except for the ship
that brought them here they're just big
hulking grunting things which they are
in this movie but I like the fact that
it shows him actually use tech in the
end Throwdown in this movie yeah the
aliens like there's a lot of them just
bludgeoning people over the head with
their fists but it does show some of
them using like the same bracelet Daniel
Craig has and a big gun like you know
the Vasquez gun from aliens yeah that
was cool so I like the movie I like the
premise I like the fact that is too
Western with an alien twist because I'm
a western fan it did concentrate on the
western aspect more than I thought it
would thought there'd be more aliens in
it and there is a part of me that's
bummed out that I didn't get the
Expendables type action you know that
action just go in there and you sit down
you turn your brain off and you're like
let's just see [ __ ] fight and die I'm
not going to knock the movie for that
I'm not going to sit here and be like
yeah the movie had a lot less mindless
action and the characters were deeper
than I thought what's up with that dude
like what [ __ ] would say that I'm not
going to say that but it lacked in
action it made up foreign characters I
enjoyed the movie I think you will too
if you know what you're going into now
you should I will say it's a good time
no alcohol required I don't know that
I'm going to go out and buy the movie on
blu-ray because I'm a really cheap
bastard but I've seen the movie already
and if my friends were all like hey
let's go out and watch cowboys and
Aliens I'd watch it with him gladly so
since this Western had surprisingly good
characters what's your favorite
character in a Western comment below let
me know doesn't have to take place on
earth either it can take place in outer
space up there in the verse and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you